une production du studio SF
[Musique]
bien le contexte dans lequel on se situe
donc ça nous a vraiment permis de
vraiment bien comprendre
ce qui se passe en fait justement
pourquoi que pourquoi qu'aujourd'hui il
se passe ça en fait le quelques semaines
il y a une jeune fille une jeune femme
iranienne qui a été tué par ce qui
apportait pas le voile correctement
selon la police des mœurs là-bas en Iran
donc ça provoqué un soulèvement
populaire comme je disais plutôt
donc c'était vraiment très éclairant
j'ai vraiment une invitée hors pair
évidemment pour bien comprendre le sujet
puis un invité hors pack qui est aussi
un affecte vraiment émotionnel avec la
situation c'est elle-même de la famille
là-bas encore tu sais c'est du stock ce
qui se passe puis tu es dans des
situations comme ça comme on le fait des
fois sans fil c'est vraiment intéressant
de pouvoir déplier la situation puis pas
juste regarder qu'est-ce qu'on voit aux
médias à chaque jour mais aussi d'en
faire la chronologie pour essayer de
comprendre
ça permet vraiment de mieux comprendre
les enjeux j'ai l'impression puis c'est
exactement ce qu'on a fait c'est que
sans plus attendre en fait la moindre tu
as quelque chose
je pense qu'il faut en parler puis c'est
ce qu'on essaie de faire aujourd'hui et
puis des fois je pose la question dans
le podcast on se posait beaucoup les
questions des fois qu'on regarde des
affaires comme ça qui se passe
international qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
puis tu sais on peut
physiquement je veux dire un peu pas
faire grand chose mais ce qu'on peut
faire c'est d'en parler plus on en parle
plus on répare l'information plus on
consiste les autres autour de nous mais
plus ça m'aide d'appréhension sur nos
élus en haut de la pression sur nos
gouvernements
occidentaux d'agir puis de de smiley de
ce qui se passe d'essayer de régler les
conflits exact donc sans plus attendre
là ça peut être magnifique conversation
mon podcast bonne écoute
le podcast de cette semaine est présenté
par Canada South je suis fier de faire
la collaboration avec Canada source
parce que c'est une compagnie chez nous
moi je vais du cynisme
c'est des sauces des condiments ketchup
moutarde religie ok
on va l'écouter live on les a pas coûté
encore je convaincu que ça va goûter
mais je vais voir la phase dedans
[Musique]
sauce ça serait une vie sans en bonheur
tu t'exprimes tes ton plaisir gustatif
moi je vais vous mentionner quelques
petits points importants par rapport à
Canada South premièrement c'est un choix
patriotique parce que
c'est Canada sauce qu'on peut les
multinationales que vous connaissez
c'est une compagnie d'ici qui fait des
produits que vous utilisez déjà mais que
vous faites sûrement vous encourager
sûrement des grosses multinationales
puis ça ici au sans fil on n'aime pas ça
c'est bon on a
[Musique]
aucun ajout chimique juste des
ingrédients 100% naturel je des
ingrédients aussi 100% canadien ce qui
est super super important dans
l'économie 360 locale la moutarde
[Applaudissements]
donc si vous voulez essayer vous même
Canada soul si on dépend de vente IgA
métro Provigo maxi Costco avril marché
102 je pense que ça s'appelle avril
juste avril connaissant
des bouteilles recyclables en vitres
impeccable c'est des produits qu'on
utilise tout le temps ketchup la
moutarde qu'on a on en met on en met
partout on en mange souvent factice
c'est parfait de pouvoir encourager
l'entreprise québécoise ingrédients
d'ici ça fait vraiment une différence
plutôt que les chaînes les géants
américains la religion
avec Canada sauce let's go le choix
logique Canada merci gang merci à Canada
SOS puis bon podcast
[Musique]
merci
le podcast de cette semaine est présenté
par menscape si vous m'écoutez en ce
moment en vidéo je me suis rendu
moustache parce que je voulais essayer
de voir de quoi ça va l'air dans Top Gun
je me suis rendu une moustache la
moustache comme tel est vraiment moyenne
ça va aussi vous êtes en short sur votre
selle ça vaut pas la peine d'aller voir
sur youtube non mais là tu avais
vraiment juste la moustache ça flasher
je trouve
avec le landmer 4.0
[Musique]
le Platinum package d'hommes qui ont
sorti qui est là
leur paquet absolu quand j'ai vu tout ce
qui avait dans ce packaging j'ai failli
tomber à ma chambre j'en croyais pas mes
yeux
puis je vois sortir la liste
[Musique]
genre un petit déodorant pour les
couilles le crop River qui est un Turner
pour les balles des boxeurs les boxeurs
c'est un grand fan des boxeurs
préférés sont vraiment confortables pour
dormir c'est excellent il y a un
travelback qui est mon travail que
j'utilise tout le la la la grande
compagnie des affaires pour se laver
dans douche donc shampoing revitalisant
deux en un body wash avec l'odeur
caractéristique de Mascate puis il y a
même la crème le spray hydratant
l'esprit hydratant j'en ai plus
tellement je l'utilise je le mets dans
mes potes quasiment à la vitesse
[Musique]
par ma peau au soleil là je suis gratté
je suis bronzé je mange dehors life is
good yeah mind skate on a code promo
pour vous autres que le sans filtre pour
20% de rabais et la livraison gratuite
sauter là-dessus comme quoi
on a juste une vie à vivre puis c'est
avec Mathieu
merci à vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci beaucoup d'être là c'est super
apprécié après une grosse soirée à
Cahors on se couche après tout le monde
encore je à l'émission s'est terminée à
22h et après il y a une autre soirée et
donc jusqu'à 1h du matin pour vous en
tout cas
mon empereur je confirme c'est vrai
les gens
merci j'espère que c'était bien c'est
toujours un peu intimidant mais voilà il
fallait en parler il fallait être là
donc c'est important pour moi et ma
collègue d'être sur place mais oui
c'était une belle expérience
qu'on a booké notre date là donc c'est
un drôle surprise de voir ton nom dans
la liste vous m'avez contacté avant tout
le monde
[Musique]
selon qui invite
là on était devant
[Rires]
aujourd'hui dans le fond tu sais nous
chaque fois que des des enjeux
internationaux comme ça on essaie de de
les simplifier ou du moins de les
expliquer et puis des déplier pour qu'on
puisse mieux les comprendre puis une
fois je pense qu'on comprend mieux ces
enjeux-là ça nous permet d'être du moins
d'être sans être plus actif de d'être
mieux actif de mieux savoir qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire pour pour aider
mais avant de parler de qu'est-ce qu'on
qu'est-ce qu'on vit maintenant qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce qui est en train de se
passer en Iran je pense que c'est
important d'essayer de comprendre un peu
l'histoire de du pays puis d'essayer de
comprendre comment on en est rendu là
c'est parce que plusieurs plusieurs
étapes puis je pense qu'on pourrait
peut-être faire un petit une petite
chronologie des événements pour essayer
de mieux comprendre je sais pas où
est-ce qu'on pourrait commencer le c'est
tout à l'expertise je lance oui on va
pas aller trop loin on peut parler on
peut commencer avec l'avènement de la
République islamique d'Iran on peut
commencer accès à par cette histoire
qu'est-ce qui a fait en fait finalement
qui a eu un changement de régime et
qu'est-ce qui a fait finalement qu'on
est en présence d'un d'un État qui est
donc un régime qu'on qu'on claque les
filles de régime théocratique
et le nom officiel du pays et ça se
nomme en fait une République islamique
d'Iran il y a une révolution en 1979
donc à 43 ans plus exactement et il y a
eu un changement de régime on est passé
d'une monarchie constitutionnelle donc
c'était la dernière dynastie la dynastie
par la vie et suite à cette révolution
il y a eu un changement de régime au
départ c'était une révolution iranienne
parce que généralement pourquoi on fait
une révolution dans un pays c'est parce
qu'on veut une amélioration des
conditions on veut justement plus de
justice sociale on veut on veut
améliorer sa vie et le gouvernement ou
le régime ou le type de régime qui est
en place ne nous représente plus et la
révolution quel était le régime là ça
ressemble à quoi avant cette révolution
là
c'était une monarchie constitutionnelle
le chat d'Iran c'est certain que ce pays
n'a jamais vraiment connu de
l'expérience démocratique donc on peut
pas dire non plus qu'à l'époque du
château était démocratique
le mot en persan pour dire le Candy le
chat d'Iran c'est le roi d'Iran donc la
famille par la vie on a connu le père et
ensuite le fils et ils ont vraiment
marqué l'histoire de l'Iran parce qu'ils
ont amené une politique de modernisation
et d'industrialisation je pense que
peut-être si maintenant avec du recul on
analyse un peu l'histoire peut-être que
toute cette politique de de
modernisation et d'industrialisation ça
fait trop trop vite et ça a suscitait
beaucoup de mécontentements au niveau de
la société à tous les étapes
la classe moyenne lui reprochait
finalement le manque d'ouverture
politique il y avait pas vraiment de
parti politique il y avait une police
aussi quand même une police politique
qui était la SAVA qui est éliminée quand
même tous les opposants ou laisser
aucune place à l'opposition ensuite
c'est certain que les paraly
contrairement à la République islamique
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui ils étaient
pas vraiment en faveur de la religion
dans la cité donc c'est certain qui
regardaient beaucoup vers l'Occident les
prenaient exemple sur l'Occident prenez
exemple sur les États-Unis prenez
exemple sur l'Europe et aspirer en fait
à devenir une grande puissance le chat
lui-même disait on veut être le gendarme
du Golfe on veut véritablement jouer non
seulement un rôle clé et majeur au moins
une Orient mais dans le monde et il se
voyait au même niveau que la France que
l'Allemagne en 1935 l'Allemagne était le
premier partenaire commercial de l'Iran
le père par la vie crée la première
université l'Université de Téhéran qui
était une université moderne et encore
une fois contrairement à ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui on allait vers une
émancipation des femmes on avait des
femmes ministres on avait des femmes qui
étaient qui avaient accès à tous les
postes et c'est vrai que
les par la vie soi-même le reconnaître
ça on peut être critique par rapport à
des monarchies on peut être critique par
rapport à des types de gouvernement mais
il faut aussi laisser souligner ce
qu'ils ont laissé comme like ce qu'ils
ont laissé comme like à la génération
d'aujourd'hui
dont moi j'en fais partie aussi
c'est tout en fait cette culture de
l'éducation ils ont un véritablement
fait en sorte que même dans les zones
les plus reculées de l'Iran on puisse
avoir accès à l'éducation il a envoyé
les meilleurs éléments ça ça s'appelait
à l'époque il appelait ça c'était dans
ses dans sa révolution blanche et la
révolution blanche et il avait mis comme
ça toute une sorte de réforme non
seulement au niveau éducatif mais aussi
dans l'agriculture sauf que veut pas le
fait de vouloir moderniser de manière
aussi intense un pays qui était
peut-être pas prêt et qui était aussi un
pays qui était quand même pris avec ses
pesanteurs culturelles avec ses réserves
etc c'est sûr que ça a suscité beaucoup
de mécontentements donc finalement la
classe moyenne lui a reproché le manque
d'ouverture politique les religieux lui
ont leur on leur a repro finalement de
manque de religion et le fait justement
de vouloir écarter la religion de de
l'espace public et politique et puis de
l'autre côté il y avait les agriculteurs
qui étaient pas non plus très contents
parce que il est venu en modernisant
toute l'agriculture du pays et ses
agriculteurs n'étaient pas prêts c'est
comme si du jour au lendemain on vient
vous vous imposer des machines des
grèves une agriculture assez sauvage et
les agriculteurs n'étaient pas du tout
prêts donc voyez différentes groupes
sociales se sont réunis et c'est un
petit peu ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
différents groupes de population se sont
réunis en disant mais on veut plus du
chat le chat
c'est un mégalomane il avait fait bon
les grandes on le reconnaît aussi dans
l'histoire avec les grandes fêtes de
Persepolis il voulait en fait il avait
un côté très
mégalomane pardon et c'est vrai que il
avait ce désir et cette volonté de
montrer en fait au monde entier que
l'Iran était un grand empire plus de
2500 ans d'histoire que l'Iran pouvait
véritablement jouer un rôle clé dans le
monde
mais évidemment la population
sentait que ils étaient ils arrivaient
pas à suivre en fait cette ces ambitions
exactement donc ou en fait il y a eu un
clash le chat est parti plusieurs fois
on exil et c'est vrai que l'exil qu'il a
connu en 1979 en tout cas ça a été
présenté au départ comme un départ en
vacances et puis il est plus jamais
revenu c'est une longue vacances
permanentes et malheureusement pour lui
il est tombé malade il a eu un cancer il
est décédé pendant pendant son exil dans
des dans des conditions assez
catastrophiques puisque finalement à
chaque fois quand ils allaient dans un
pays après quelques temps on leur
demandait de repartir et tous ces alliés
se sont tournés un peu contre eux donc
finalement pour la famille par la ville
exil qu'ils ont suivi après ce
changement de régime ça a été
véritablement
finalement un long chemin à cette
tortueux et assez difficile bon
maintenant il a il a ses héritiers bon
aussi la famille il avait de filles et
de garçons sur les quatre enfants il y
en a plus que deux qui sont vivants donc
il y a son fils aîné maintenant qui
pourrait éventuellement en tout cas pour
ceux qui sont promo anarchistes et pro
royalistes ils le voient comme une
alternative comme un peu l'héritier
comme du trône la reine évidemment
faradyba bon elle a plus le statut de
Rennes d'Iran mais on l'appelle Farah
Diba et c'est vrai que pour certains
c'est toujours elle est toujours elle a
une légitimité pour ceux qui sont
évidemment pro royalistes et puis c'est
certain que ils ont pas non plus une
légitimité ou en tout cas ils ont pas
des partisans non plus partout
internationaux non non c'est ça il y a
des gens qui sont en faveur et qui les
respectent et puis surtout je pense que
le fait aussi que la population
iranienne a vu qu'est-ce qui est venu
après je pense qu'ils ont d'autant plus
de respect pour le régime il y a eu
comme ça en fait une nostalgie même pour
pour le régime précédent et ce qui est
d'autant plus intéressant si on parle
des jeunes générations des gens de
génération les gens de notre génération
aujourd'hui reproche à leur propre
parent d'avoir fait la révolution en
disant mais qu'est-ce que vous avez fait
vous vous viviez super bien il y avait
pas de voix obligatoire vous buvez de
l'alcool vous partez en vacances on
avait de vous avez une meilleure
condition de vie bon tout était pas
parfait mais si vous voulez la
génération d'aujourd'hui a eu tendance à
reprocher à leur propre parents en
disant
vous avez amené en fait une république
islamique et nous on est on est cette
génération on est né sous une république
islamique mais à avoir pu choisir on
aurait pu on aurait voulu naître dans un
dans une ou en tout cas une monarchie ou
en tout cas un éthano islamique
islamique donc c'est exactement
aujourd'hui ce qu'il en est c'est
vraiment la question de dire finalement
c'est pas une société islamique qu'on
veut et
donc vous voyez c'est d'où les tensions
aussi parfois où il y a eu par moment
justement entre des générations et on
arrive donc avec l'arrivée de Roumanie
en 1979 Romani qu'il faut pas oublier il
a été accueilli à bras ouvert par la
France il a il a été exilé en Irak à
Nadia et ensuite il a connu 15 ans
d'exil le chat pouvait en fait c'était
un des opposants du chat et on avait
conseillé pour la petite histoire on
avait conseillé au chat d'Iron en disant
ben écoutez vous avez comme ça des
opposants dont un qui est Romani à
l'époque il était pas un œillette là
mais en tout cas il y avait cette figure
religieuse qui était farouchement contre
même le père de Romani était contre le
par la vie donc il y avait évidemment
toute cette historique finalement de
famille religieuses qui s'opposaient à
la dynastie et par la vie et le chat
prend la décision
de ne pas l'éliminer physiquement et de
l'envoyer en exil donc l'Iran a connu
comme ça toute une série d'exilés
politiques et Roumanie fait partie de
ces grandes figures d'exilés 15 ans en
exil en Irak et le plus surprenant
aujourd'hui c'est que la France la
République laïque française a accueilli
sur son territoire pendant 112 jours
romain à Paris en France à
neuf-le-château c'était sous Giscard
d'Estaing et aujourd'hui vous savez
beaucoup d'Iraniens envol aussi à la
France en disant finalement cette figure
religieuse et politique qu'aujourd'hui
nous on rejette vous vous l'avez
accueilli quand même sur votre
territoire et surtout sur un territoire
qui a aussi finalement ses battu pour
pour mettre en place la laïcité alors
vous voyez toute la dynamique et les
tensions est-ce qu'on le perso
de plutôt radical ou plutôt modéré à
l'époque mettons
soit renversé
c'est une bonne question ça dépend de
quel enclenche se situe
Roumanie en fait qu'est-ce qui a plu
dans son discours et parce qu'il a
préparait quand même son Iran il a à
l'époque on parlait pas de révolution
tutar on parlait de la révolution des
cassettes il enregistré sur des
cassettes là maintenant peut-être que ça
a dit pas grand chose aux personnes qui
nous écoutent
on pourra mettre une image il
enregistrait des son discours sur des
cassettes qu'on faisait circuler ben il
faisait ça ça on disait que ça circulé
sous les manteaux et puis voilà il avait
cette possibilité finalement de faire
connaître son discours à travers le pays
en étant à l'extérieur et donc qu'est-ce
qui plaisait le plus dans son dans son
discours politique et religieux parce
que à la fois il faut savoir que
remémini a emmené une idéologie
religieuse et politique de on en parlait
par la suite de l'islam politique etc
véritablement ça sa vision à lui c'était
de dire mais il faut qu'on amène une
forme de moralité spirituelle évidemment
on s'inspirant des valeurs de l'Islam en
partant des textes religieux mais il
faut évidemment que ce soit en
équation avec la justice sociale avec la
question des femmes ce qui est très
bizarre moi j'ai analysé les discours de
Romani il valorisé la femme la femme
iranienne va jouer dans la République
islamique va jouer un rôle important va
bénéficier du statut qui lui revient on
voit que 43 ans plus tard le statut qui
lui est revenu c'est une citoyenne de
seconde zone pour dire même pas
peut-être des citoyens de seconde zone
c'est à dire que les promesses qu'il a
fait et tout le cette politique
finalement gérer ce discours très
séduisant de parler de justice sociale
de de mélanger en fait un discours très
social avec un discours islamiste je
pense que ça ça a été un mariage qui a
pu faire en sorte qui s'est donné une
légitimité religieuse
et de facto une légitimité politique et
c'est un discours qui plaisait parce
qu'en fait il est venu avec un discours
en disant c'est la fin de la répression
c'est la fin de la dynastie des par la
vie qui nous ont pas écouté qui vous ont
pas qui répondent plus à vos besoins
mais nous maintenant on va être
d'ailleurs et un vocabulaire qui
l'utilisait souvent ça revenait souvent
dans ses discours c'était le vocable les
défavorisés il disait nous on va prendre
soin des défavorisés on va prendre soin
de la base on va on va partir de de la
base de la société du peuple en fait et
donc il se donnait si vous voulez il
avait ce discours quand même qui est un
discours finalement de gauche qui est un
discours qui peut séduire madame et
monsieur tout le monde en disant bah
enfin il y en a un qui va défendre notre
intérêt moi je suis ouvrier je suis
enseignante je fais pas beaucoup
d'argent je suis dans la frange
austérité et donc on a quelqu'un qui va
enfin venir défendre nos intérêts et
c'est comme ça qu'il a pu bâtir si vous
voulez un appui populaire et il arrive
donc il arrive avec Air France j'invite
à regarder les archives hillarines avec
Air France sur le territoire iranien et
on a sous-estimé si vous voulez le
pouvoir religieux en Iran on pourrait
faire le procès de beaucoup de gens
aujourd'hui on pourrait dire une des
premières choses qu'on peut reprocher
c'est les intellectuels comment les
intellectuels iraniens ont sous-estimé
le pouvoir religieux il y avait des
intellectuels à l'époque qui disaient
vous savez romenus va arriver trois
quatre mois il va apaiser les tensions
et ensuite nous on va pouvoir mettre en
place un mode un modèle de société on va
pouvoir mettre en place une nouvelle
structure politique parce que l'objectif
de la révolution au final c'est
d'instaurait une journée démocratie ou
ça jamais été dans dans l'objectif de
faire l'objectif de Romani il a dit très
vite quand il est arrivé en Iran il a
dit ni l'Ouest ni l'est donc on regarde
ni l'Union so ni l'Occident mais la
République islamique son objectif
c'était quoi c'était d'en faire un état
islamique et non seulement il disait on
va faire de l'Iran un état islamique
mais on va exporter ce modèle à
l'extérieur de l'Iran alors vous voyez
aujourd'hui on arrivait j'arrive à
l'Irak qui est juste à côté et on l'a
connu une guerre de 8 ans pourquoi en
fait l'Irak et l'Iran sont rentrés en
guerre parce que un moment donné les
pays voisins qui avaient en fait parce
que l'Iran est un il faut aussi le dire
avec Romani on a eu aussi une
institutionnalisation de ce qu'on
appelle c'est indebranches de l'islam et
qui ont majorité en Iran c'est les
chiites c'est les chutes du décima c'est
une minorité au Moyen-Orient c'est une
majorité en Iran vous avez aussi des
factions chites au Liban en Irak au
Yémen et donc tous ces factions là et
toutes ces populations chies dans les
autres pays regardez l'Iran et l'Iran
évidemment vous voyez il y a des liens
que maintenant vous pouvez faire avec au
Liban avec les chiites en Irak et ça
crée une telle tension à l'époque et
c'est vrai que Saddam Hussein a eu peur
parce que finalement il s'est dit bah
ils ont fait une révolution
en Iran ils sont capables d'en faire
aussi une ici donc évidemment après il y
avait d'autres enjeux je rentre pas trop
dans la galerie en Irak ça demanderait
tout un cours mais mais vous voyez
comment les choses sont liées et donc
dès que Romain n'y arrivait plus tard
dès 1980 l'Iran entre en gare pendant 8
ans
mais donc quand tu dis les jeunes de
notre génération rapprocher leurs
parents leur faire la révolution
personne s'attendait à ce que ça ça
tournevenait comme ça finalement on
savait que ça serait une un état
religieux mais il faisait beaucoup plus
ouvert qu'il était réellement finalement
oui oui tout le monde pensait que on
allait avoir une amélioration des choses
que on allait pas avoir évidemment une
industrialisation une modernisation
aussi rapide on pensait que finalement
aller prendre soin de la population
iranienne 43 ans plus tard maintenant on
peut faire un bilan et on peut surtout
faire un procès à cette étape parce que
finalement les promesses n'ont pas été
tenues et quand on regarde le bilan
économique le bilan social le bilan
politique et même je dirais cette
défense farouche de défense des valeurs
islamiques et une religion à travers
l'islam mais il y a un échec total
puisqu'on le voit les Iraniens pour
beaucoup d'Iraniens l'islam n'est pas
une identité et non seulement c'est pas
une identité il identité mais en plus il
rejette
tout ça parce que pour eux c'est quoi
une société islamique et synonyme de
répression de manque de liberté de
manque aux droits humains donc aux
libertés les plus fondamentales etc donc
en fait dans les années mettant dans le
contexte des années fin 70 est-ce que
c'est on avait on avait un étau où le
politique et le religieux
des sommes toutes plus séparés est-ce
que les gens étaient très religieux à
cette époque-là et est-ce que un
discours religieux ça justement ça
raisonner beaucoup chez les gens ce que
c'était ça qui ou c'était plus d'autres
aspects oui non c'est à la fois vous
avez en Iran on fait c'est ça peut-être
la complexité du pays parce que vous
avez à la fois dans ce pays c'est l'Iran
c'est une mosaïque de peuple et donc
vous avez différentes ethnies vous avez
différents religions vous avez en Iran
des chrétiens les gens comme ça au moins
vous savez il y a des églises qui se
trouvent à Teyran vous avez des Juifs
vous avez vraiment des quartiers juifs
atterrants et dans d'autres dans
d'autres coins du pays donc vous voyez
juif chrétien musulmans vous aviez les
eurosastriens qui précèdent en fait
l'islam en Iran et donc vous aviez comme
ça différentes croyances différentes
ethnies différentes religions donc tout
le monde n'était pas oui peut-être qu'il
y avait une partie de la population qui
était croyante et même encore
aujourd'hui il y a une partie de la
population qui est qui est croyante et
pratiquante aussi mais c'est difficile
aujourd'hui à mesurer à vous donner des
statistiques parce que ni à l'époque ni
aujourd'hui on a vraiment pu faire en
fait finalement des statistiques qui
reflètent quelle est la réalité puis
vous avez aujourd'hui aussi beaucoup
d'Iraniens qui sont héritiers en fait
d'une culture je dirais religieuse ou
[Musique]
héritiers un peu d'une famille dont la
croyance a occupé une place importante
mais que même ne sont pas du tout
pratiquants vous avez beaucoup
d'Iraniens qui boivent de l'alcool qui
font pas le ramadan enfin voilà c'est
pas et c'est pas considéré comme
dramatique pour beaucoup d'entre eux à
moins que vous venez vraiment d'une
famille très pieuse très religieuse
souvent on retrouve sa famille là c'est
souvent des familles qui sont un lien
avec l'État aujourd'hui soit vous
retrouver des familles qui sont
croyantes dans des zones les plus
rurales où les ondes les plus reculées
et ça veut pas non plus dire parce que
vous êtes croyant et que vous êtes
pratiquant que vous êtes trop régime ça
il faut pas il faut pas faire un
amalgame puis puis c'est sûr que dans un
véritable de droit il faudrait en fait
laisser aussi le droit de culte sauf que
la grosse confusion aujourd'hui qui se
fait c'est que tout de suite on en
associe aujourd'hui l'islam avec la
République islamique avec la répression
et en 1979 comment est-ce que ça se
passe le renversement de régime comment
est-ce que concrètement ça arrive est-ce
que c'est des manifestations extrêmement
violentes est-ce que c'est des centaines
de morts
dans les rues on voit dans les photos
d'archives beaucoup de gens dans les
rues une vraie véritablement une vraie
révolution et encore si on fait une
comparaison avec ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui même si aujourd'hui il faut
être prudent sur le terme révolution je
pense que ce qui est intéressant c'est
que le chat a compris sa population et
il s'est dit ils veulent pas de moi je
vais partir aussi pour un peu un petit
peu calmé les tensions et
c'est quand même à son honneur d'être
parti en disant finalement ma population
ne veut plus de moi donc je pars et vous
savez il y a une expression
personne qui dit on a fait sortir un
chat on en a fait rentrer des centaines
et c'est assez vrai parce que finalement
on se on est pris maintenant avec un
régime qui ne veut pas partir et qui
résiste et qui et qui veut même pas en
fait reconnaître qui n'a plus de
légitimité auprès d'une grande partie de
la population alors que le dernier roi
d'Iran même si j'imagine avec tout ce
que cela a pu avoir comme conséquence
pour lui et sa famille ils ont quitté le
pays et moi je trouve que ça demande une
grandeur d'arme à un moment donné de
dire finalement on veut pas de moi donc
je m'en vais j'ai plus de de ma
souveraineté n'est plus légitime je ne
suis plus reconnue je ne suis pas la
population ne se sont pas représentées
donc je m'en vais mais c'est pas ce
qu'on retrouve aujourd'hui avec ce qu'on
voyait véritablement on va en parler
d'aujourd'hui mais pour revenir à la
Révolution oui et quand le chat est
parti
on regarde aujourd'hui les images les
gens étaient il y avait de l'euphorie
les gens sortaient dans la rue ils
dansaient les femmes qui n'étaient pas
voilées ça c'est extraordinaire moi j'ai
des photos d'archives où on voit des
jeunes femmes des femmes magnifiques
qui sont évidemment pas voilés et qui
klaxonnaient ils disaient le chat est
parti le chat est parti le chat ne
reviendra plus c'est Chris sur les sur
les slogans et donc il y avait une
euphorie les gens dansaient klaxonnaient
etc il y avait une euphorie comme ça
dans la société quand le chat est parti
mais cette forêt a été de très courte
durée avant que les gens réalisent que
le haut il y a quelque chose d'autre ils
ont réalisé en quelques mois en quelques
mois romain une idée qu'il est arrivé
sur le territoire iranien Roumanie a mis
en place il a tout changé les références
les manuels scolaires
tout a changé on interdit l'alcool on
impose une des premiers dans tout ce qui
est norme religieuse dans les codes de
conduite une
des premières choses une des premières
choses qu'il a imposées c'est ce fameux
code vestimentaire pour les femmes et
pour les hommes aussi interdiction de
porter la cravate
pas de jeans pas de jeans troué pas de
vêtements serrés le tchader noir donc
c'est ce fameux trader noir c'est pas
comme la burka il faut pas confondre en
Iran on cache pas le visage c'est le
fameux j'adore noir qui vous couvre de
la tête aux pieds et puis après
évidemment le vêtement islamique c'est à
dire un manteau le voile les cheveux
cachés et donc voilà concrètement puis
toute la législation a changé la cote de
la famille a disparu il a il a mis il a
il est revenu sur tous les acquis par
exemple que les femmes les femmes
avaient eu pendant l'époque du chat il a
complètement il les a complètement
supprimés de la législation on s'est
retrouvé en fait il a mis très vite en
place qu'on appelle la charia donc la
loi
islamique et donc de la sensation suivie
toute une série de discrimination pour
les femmes Inter de voyage à l'étranger
sans l'accord de leur mari de leurs
frères ou de leur tuteurs ou de leur
part en fonction des cas en termes
d'héritage en termes de divorce
gardez-enfants tout a changé et c'est
vrai que pour les femmes ça a été ça a
été terrible parce que du jour au
lendemain leur condition c'est
complètement détérioré mais quand vous
avez une société où la condition
féminine est détériorée la condition
humaine est détériorée la condition des
enfants les relations homme-femmes ont
été complètement revues vous pouvez plus
tenir la main de votre petit ami de
votre petit copain plus de bisous dans
l'espace public enfin voilà vous voyez
vous avez eu comme ça avec l'arrivée de
Roumanie et toutes les organes qu'il a
mis en place il a mis en place toute une
série d'organes répressives on pourra
parler notamment de cette fameuse police
de mœurs police de moralité mais hormis
ça il a mis tout en place des organes de
contrôle de surveillance le but c'était
quoi c'était de vraiment progressivement
à dès le début de la de la Révolution
jusqu'à aujourd'hui d'encadrer
progressivement la société dans son
ensemble
et à partir de là
jusqu'à maintenant est-ce qu'il y a eu
des tentatives de
révolution ou du moins de démonstration
de manifestations à quoi ça ressemble 43
ans 43 ans
publique sur ce
gouvernement entre guillemets le est-ce
que j'imagine que changer assez
rapidement que l'appui quand on s'est
rendu compte que c'est ce qui se passait
est-ce que les gens automatiquement sont
sortis puis on décrié ce régime là où ça
a pris du temps avant qu'il gagne
s'installe oui ça a pris un peu de temps
parce qu'on savait pas trop à quoi
s'attendre le temps que ils mettent en
place ces infrastructures pour qu'ils
changent
d'autant les références si vous voulez
au niveau de la société au niveau
politique etc
mais très vite enfin très vite les gens
pensaient que de toute façon ils
pensaient peut-être entre guillemets que
les choses allaient s'améliorer et que
finalement ce qu'ils étaient en train de
se mettre en place peut-être les gens
donnaient du temps c'était un peu le cas
de beaucoup de parents justement cette
génération qui ont fait la révolution
ils sont dit ben on va voir il arrive on
va peut-être avoir des améliorations on
sait pas voilà on a fait une révolution
le chat est parti donc maintenant
peut-être qu'on va avoir une vie
meilleure parce que souvent c'est ça
qu'on inspire on veut tous une vie
meilleure on veut tous une amélioration
de notre condition sociale politique
économique sauf que dès les années 1980
un des premiers groupes à avoir
manifesté contre contre la République
islamique c'était justement les femmes
là aussi les photos d'archives nous
montrent que dès 1980 les femmes étaient
mais surtout dans ce type de
manifestation elles étaient pas du tout
voilées et elles ont protesté contre le
port obligatoire du voile elles étaient
pas pour le fait que on ne puisse pas
porter le voile mais toute la question
du voile en Iran c'est sur ce question
de choix on veut pas qu'elle soit
obligatoire après c'est une femme pour
des raisons de croyances de foie etc
souhaite porter le jabraël évidemment de
disposer de de son salaire liberté du
culte et sa liberté individuelle mais ce
que beaucoup de femmes iraniennes ont
réclamé dès le début de dire mais on
n'est pas du tout d'accord avec le fait
que ce soit obligatoire en fait
donc ça ça a été le premier groupe
ensuite on a une gare de 8 ans donc dans
une gare vous faites pas vraiment de
manifestations après une guerre la
première chose qui est importante pour
un pays c'est se relever économiquement
donc vous voyez ça a donné du temps à la
République à bien s'installer un des
premiers mouvements qui a eu lieu au
moins une Orient et avant le printemps
arabe ça a été ce fameux mouvement Var
là voyons on avance un peu dans le temps
de manière chronologique le Mouvement
Vert éclate en 2009 en juin 2009 c'était
les élections présidentielles à ma ligne
jade arrive au pouvoir et les jeunes
Iraniens et une partie de la population
ce sont pas du tout représentés par un
made inadja en disant mais nous on a
voté pour un autre candidat et on se
sent pas du tout bah en fait on
considère que notre vote n'a pas été
respectée alors les slogans qui ont
suivi dans ce mouvement c'était de dire
où est passé mon vote
il y a eu tricherie il y a eu fraude
nous on est on a voté pour un autre
candidat on avait voté pour un
réformateur on veut pas encore d'un
conservateur il avait déjà fait un
mandat de 4 ans là elle était temps de
changer juste pour presser parce que
j'ai bien compris comme deux pouvoirs en
Iran en fait que le Guide de la
révolution lui qui est toujours là puis
il y a aussi des élections puis un
président qui est élu c'est bien ça oui
exactement c'est très complexe en fait
vous avez donc ce qu'on appelle le guide
suprême le guide supram souvent on dit
mais finalement c'est qui le véritable
chef de l'État elle le ferait guide de
chef de l'État c'est le guide suprême
le guide suprême n'a pas été élu il a
été finalement
il est il est il est il a été choisi par
le guide suprême précédent donc le
premier a été remis et là en ce moment
ça allait ramener ensuite vous avez des
élections pour élire le Président donc
ça c'est ça sonne jamais bien suprême
quelque chose qui est comme commandant
suprême c'est bizarre mais c'est
l'esprit c'est l'esprit c'est de dire
finalement il est il est au-dessus de la
mêlée il a le pouvoir absolu il a le
pouvoir de l'armée il a le pouvoir des
médias c'est lui qui intervient en
dernière position vous savez le terme
République islamique est une
contradiction en soi parce que vous avez
en fait tous les éléments d'une
république en Iran d'ailleurs ça va vous
paraître bizarre mais la Constitution
iranienne qui existe aujourd'hui a été
inspiré de la Constitution belge et
française et parce que Romani était en
France il faut pas oublier donc en fait
toute cette notion de représentativité
de République il s'en est inspiré
comment comme il était en France il a
peut-être en fait peut-être qu'il a pas
prélèvements compris non plus l'esprit
de d'une république parce que finalement
il a amené en Iran toute cette structure
politique donc c'est vraiment étrange
parce que quand on regarde la
constitution et la structure politique
en Iran ce qui est intéressant c'est que
vous retrouvez des éléments qu'on peut
retrouver dans une république une
constitution un parlement des élections
vous avez la division des pouvoirs
judiciaires exécutive et législatives et
vous dites mais c'est magnifique c'est
extraordinaire un pays au moins une
Orient il y a cette et puis là on creuse
et là on voit que en fait
tout se tient dans le sens où finalement
les indépendent des autres et au sommet
du pouvoir c'est qui c'est ce fameux
guide suprême qui décide et qu'il est
gifère pour tout le monde qui est
au-dessus finalement du président qui
est élu qui est au-dessus évidemment
parce que souvent d'ailleurs ça c'est
intéressant il y avait des journalistes
qui disaient mais finalement les
Iraniens ont un président mais c'est pas
véritablement lu qui qui décide donc
c'est qui qui décide véritablement dans
votre pays et c'est que c'est une bonne
question dans le sens où on sait pas
véritablement qui décide dans ce pays
vous avez comme ça différents conseils
vous avez des Gardiens de la Révolution
vous avez un conseil de clergé qu'on
parle de 80 clergé qui sont derrière le
guide suprême enfin voilà après il y a
pas beaucoup de transparence on sait pas
véritablement qui prend les décisions ce
qu'on sait aujourd'hui c'est que c'est
le guide suprême c'est le guide donc le
terme guide le guide de la de le guide
supram qui guide les autres et qui dit
finalement la voix à suivre et
d'ailleurs on aujourd'hui il y a des il
y a des il y a des rumeurs qui courent
aussi comme quoi il est malade parce
qu'il est très vieux et on pense qu'il
aime qu'il est malade donc il va
peut-être décéder dans peu de temps donc
aussi c'est toute la question si lui
vient à décéder qu'est-ce qui va arriver
parce que là aussi on va peut-être
arriver à une explosion une révolution
suite à l'annonce de son de son décès ça
parce que c'est
ça pourrait être une opportunité ça
pourrait être une belle fenêtre
d'opportunité donc ça c'est vraiment à
suivre mais bon il a intervenu dans les
médias pour aussi montrer qu'il était là
évidemment il a condamné les
protestations actuelles il a il a noté
que il montrerait enfin le gouvernement
va montrer aucune indulgence vis-à-vis
de des manifestants et des
protestataires mais c'est ça donc pour
revenir à votre question qui était dans
la suite oui les revendications on était
rendus en 2009 allez revenons en 2009
merci merci pour revenir en 2009 mais il
faut il faut aussi le dire quand même
moi j'ai regardé même en avant 2009 si
on regarde aussi des années 90 97 2003
il y a eu des petits moments de il y a
eu des des protestations mais à chaque
fois ça a été écrasé dans l'oeuf et puis
à l'époque on n'avait pas les réseaux
sociaux on n'avait pas une visibilité
aussi large je pense que ce qui a donné
aussi beaucoup la lumière au Mouvement
Vert en 2009 c'était que finalement on
avait des journalistes cit qui prenait
le cellulaire qui filmait les réseaux
sociaux relayés sur Youtube on faisait
des photos on montrait aussi le visage
de la répression donc déjà à ce moment
là il y avait des scènes qui étaient qui
étaient des graines pardon qui était qui
était semées et
ce qu'on voit là aussi ça a été
malheureusement écrasé écrasé je dirais
ça a été complètement étouffé par le
gouvernement parce que la répression est
devenue un mode de gouvernance c'est
vraiment ça à chaque fois était la
réponse à ces systématique de ce
gouvernement c'est-à-dire que à chaque
fois qu'on les gens se mobilisent
protestent contestent critique l'État ou
remettre en question ou au moins disent
mais nous revenons sur le système de
vote nous on a voté pour un candidat
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé on a on a joué
le jeu on a joué le jeu politique parce
que c'est vrai qu'il faut dire aussi que
en Iran ce qu'on voit ça que en ce
moment et depuis de nombreuses années il
y a un grand taux d'absence séisme mais
quand ils sont rendus aux urnes et
qu'ils ont voté que les gens appelés en
masse en disant non non allez voter
c'est important même si vous n'êtes pas
d'accord avec le système un moment il
faut qu'on puisse changer le système de
l'Intérieur donc ce jeune là qui avait
beaucoup d'espoir se sont rendus aux
urnes alors que peut-être ils y
croyaient pas mais là encore une fois
ils ont eu la confirmation que
finalement on respectait pas leur choix
donc vous voyez comment les choses cette
frustration
commence en fait à croître moi moi je
parle en fait d'une la paire de
légitimité de l'État je la considère dès
2005 moi je pense que dès 2005 il y a eu
cette légitimité politique a commencé à
s'effriter et puis ce qu'on a vu pour
revenir au mouvement de protestation
depuis la fin 2017 jusqu'à aujourd'hui
là maintenant c'est ça fait partie en
fait je dirais vous avez depuis fin 2017
on a connu comme ça si vous voulez une
vague de protestation assez périodique
sur des enjeux différents tantôt c'était
le prix de l'essence qui avait augmenté
tantôt c'était malheureusement avec le
vol 500 750 2
post-avion finalement civil qui a été
qui a reçu du missile donc à chaque fois
vous auriez il y a eu des moments
déclencheurs où les gens ont manifesté
soit pour souligner justement les
bavures de l'État le fait que l'État ne
respectent pas finalement ses
responsabilités prend pas ses
engagements qui est complètement
inefficace ok qui répond trop
tardivement à des problèmes que ce soit
des enjeux environnementaux que ce soit
au niveau de l'économie parce que c'est
aussi ce pays connaît un chômage
endémique il y a un taux d'inflation qui
qui en croissance peu importe où vous
prenez quel aspect de la vie de des
Iraniens on voit que finalement c'est
une population qui n'en peut plus en
fait qui n'ont plus parce que à chaque
fois ils sont confrontés à un état qui
prend pas ses responsabilités et il y a
une perte de confiance aujourd'hui ce
qu'on voit c'est un peu la conclusion de
plusieurs années de perte de confiance à
l'état l'État ne remplit pas son contrat
social d'ailleurs moi je pense qu'il y a
jamais eu de contrat social à un moment
donné un état un des obligations
vis-à-vis de sa population il doit
garantir la sécurité il doit se garantir
un minimum de bien-être
ce minimum de bien-être ça n'existe pas
non non
et puis surtout ça c'est jamais fait en
fait concrètement dans les faits ça
c'est jamais fait
ce qui nous amène à le quelques semaines
le 1 mois exactement
l'élément déclencheur je pense qu'on a
tous entendu parler la mort de
monsieur
peux-tu nous expliquer un petit peu le
contexte autour de ça oui absolument en
fait ce qui s'est passé au mois de
septembre c'est que une jeune fille
nommée à 5 minutes de 22 ans d'origine
kurde est venu à téran elle était en
vacances
comme n'importe quel jeune fille qui
veut venir un peu des régions ils ont
quelqu'un lien de région tu viens à
Montréal tu veux passer une fin de
semaine voilà elle est venue elle a dans
la capitale pour passer à un séjour en
famille et la police de mars elle était
voilée il faut il faut rappeler qu'elle
n'était pas non voilée elle était voilée
mais la police démarre en tout cas à
considérer que c'était une tenue
inappropriée auquel était mal voilée il
y a même en fait cette expression qui
existe depuis d'ailleurs l'avènement la
République islamique qui font des
catégories entre les biens voilés les
malvoilés donc malheureusement pour elle
elle est tombée dans la catégorie de mal
voilée et
des images qui ont circulé par la suite
c'est que elle a reçu certainement un
coup à la tête ça c'est souvent ce qui
se passe quand parfois il y a comme ça
des arrestations il y a des arrestations
arbitraires dès que vous êtes en
intercarcation avec ce type d'organes de
police ou ici en l'occurrence c'était la
police des mœurs de la moralité
je veux dire le le
il se donne en fait aucune retenue dans
la violence physique donc vous êtes
exposé à des risques ça peut être un
coup de bâton ça peut être un coup à la
tête ça peut en tout cas ça va il y a
une violence physique qui peut venir pas
toujours systématiquement mais en tout
cas il y a des grands il y a des grandes
chances qui recouvre à une violence
physique et donc cette jeune femme tombe
dans le commun pendant trois jours
ils l'ont amené dans une sorte de maison
de
de rééducation de des cas de CV c'est
quoi ce exactement
c'est pas très clair vous savez les
informations qui nous sont venues ce qui
est important à savoir c'est que cette
jeune femme elle a subi un tel coup
qu'elle est tombé dans le coma et que 3
jours après les décédé alors ce qui est
le plus frappant c'est que cet état
c'est justifié par la suite en disant
mais non non mais elle avait un problème
c'est une tumeur de cerveau elle avait
un problème au niveau sarabral ça nous
concerne pas du tout donc ils se sont
tout de suite des responsabilisés de sa
mort alors que quand on écoute la
famille de Marcin Amini elle était en
parfaite santé pour quelle raison une
jeune femme de 22 ans doit avoir des
problèmes de santé au niveau cérébral si
c'était le cas elle aurait eu
certainement un suivi médical enfin
voilà c'est toujours très
disproportionnelle entre l'acte et le
geste posé puis après la justification
qui s'en vient ça démontre encore une
fois à quel point le le ce que la
population iranienne ressent à chaque
fois c'est que il y a du mensonge ce
gouvernement ment ce coup de
gouvernement n'est pas transparent on
sait pas exactement ce qui s'est fait
dans quelles conditions ça c'est fait il
y a toujours comme ça un flou une
transparence qui circule il y a des
choses que la famille dit et qui
certainement je pense pas qu'on peut
remettre en question ils viennent de
perdre quand même la vie de leur enfant
donc c'est très problématique et le
problème avec Martin et Minnie c'est que
malheureusement malheureusement
elle fait partie d'une longue liste de
victimes avant elle il y en a eu
d'autres de Marsa à minuit il y a une
aide à par exemple pendant le mouvement
vert qui a reçu une balle en plein cœur
cette jeune fille elle s'est vidée de
son sang en plein dans la rue de Téhéran
qui est d'ailleurs devenu une visage
emblématique du mouvement vert il y a eu
tellement d'autres d'autres cas je vous
fais la vis la vis on sera encore là
demain et malheureusement on voit que ce
qui est le plus étonnant c'est que donc
l'état c'est donner donc finalement le
droit de vie et de mort sur cette jeune
femme et qu'aujourd'hui il tue des
milliers et des centaines de personne
pour dire mais on n'a pas tué Martin et
Minnie alors vous justifiez en fait le
fait que vous avez pas tué une personne
alors qu'est-ce que vous faites en ce
moment qu'est-ce qu'il est en train de
se faire parce que là ce qui est en
train de se faire il y a non seulement
du féminicide on peut on peut vraiment
le dire dans cet arbre là on cible les
femmes on cible les femmes non voilées
les femmes vous avez vu le voile est
devenu aussi un moment déclencheur
puisque Martin et Minnie est quand même
morte il faut le dire pour deux mèches
de cheveux et puis aujourd'hui ce qu'on
est en train de voir c'est aussi en plus
du féminisme il y a aussi des enfants
anticides on tue des enfants aujourd'hui
en Iran à l'heure où je suis en train de
vous parler ils sont en train de tuer à
balle réel sur la population et donc
c'est ça en fait une un état qui se
donne le droit de vie le droit de vie et
de mort sur chaque citoyen ils utilisent
des armes ils sont super équipés depuis
2009 d'ailleurs ils se sont rendus
compte que la société s'organise que la
société va sur l'espace public et donc
maintenant on a toute une structure
moderne ils ont des équipements ils sont
très très bien protégés ils ont des
casques ils ont des gilets alors que la
population ce qui est le plus drôle
c'est que la population elle a même pas
armée et c'est ça qui est le plus
terrible et c'est ça qui est je trouve
qui qui montre à quel point parce que ce
côté on est vraiment en fait
c'est difficile d'en parler pour moi
mais je trouve qu'on est on est arrivé à
dans un état où il y a plus d'humanisme
en fait il y a plus d'humanisme comment
vous vous donnez ce droit de tuer les
enfants
de de sa famille vous vous tuez les
enfants de la République c'est des
enfants de la République mais c'est des
enfants d'une république qui remettent
en question la tribu islamique et c'est
c'est au prix de leur vie finalement que
ces gens là critiquent un état dans
lequel il ne se reconnaissent plus tout
simplement on se reconnaît pas dans cet
état on se reconnaît pas dans le
discours politique on se reconnaît pas
dans les règles morales et religieuses
islamique imposé par l'État mais est-ce
que la réponse à ça c'est la mort
est-ce qu'on assassine une personne
parce qu'on partage pas on voyait c'est
ça qui est très catastrophique parce
qu'on je vous parle de ça on est en 2022
on est presque en 2023 et et donc le
point déclencheur pour revenir à ce
mouvement oui a été un Massa mini a été
la mort de cette jeune fille mais
maintenant il y a eu tellement d'autres
morts de jeunes des moins jeunes des
plus jeunes
et ça dépasse aujourd'hui je pense la
question du voile ça dépasse la question
du code vestimentaire là on est rendu
ailleurs dans dans les mouvements de
mobilisation
oui aujourd'hui c'est vraiment c'est
très clair dans les slogans c'est mort à
la dictature on ne veut plus de la
République islamique partez on ne veut
plus de vous
et liberté liberté au début le slogan
majeur qui est beaucoup sorti de cette
de ces manifestation cette femme vit
liberté évidemment femme c'était toute
la question liée à ma sœur évidemment la
question du voile parce que ça fait 43
ans que ça fait un moment on leur dit
finalement quoi porter quoi faire
de quelle manière exister en fait c'est
véritablement ça puis le deuxième mot
qui est vide évidemment
c'est toute cette
ce respect vis-à-vis de la vie humaine
que l'État n'a plus l'État n'a plus
aucun respect ne donne aucune valeur à
la vie humaine est-ce que la répression
c'est c'est endurci avec le temps
j'imagine que oui absolument la
répression a toujours été là la
répression a été toujours là mais elle
l'a montré différentes visages au fur et
à mesure et ce qu'on sait pas
aujourd'hui c'est juste que jusqu'où
elle va aller et de quoi elle est
capable parce qu'il y a plus de limites
en fait dont le déploiement de cette
force est de cette violence brutale
parce que c'est vraiment de la brutalité
il y a pas de retenue il y a pas de
limite
et c'est ça en fait qui est très
dangereux parce que c'est un état qui a
aussi les moyens un équipement très
moderne ultra moderne j'utilise du gaz
lacrymogène ils utilisent des jets d'eau
mais à la limite si ça te sente n'est
qu'un ça mais il tire des balles real
maintenant non ils sont armés c'est une
population enfin c'est un état pardon
pas une population c'est un état qui est
armé la population par contre elle est
désormais la population n'est pas armée
donc vous tirez en fait sur des civils
et et c'est ça qui est le plus je pense
le plus inacceptable et le plus qui
indigne aujourd'hui je pense des
Iraniens de partout dans le monde les
Iraniens qui habitent en Iran et je
pense que iranien ou non
on peut pas accepter l'inacceptable
est-ce qu'on peut appeler ça une guerre
civile en ce moment ce qui se passe en
Iran pour être honnête avec vous je ne
sais pas comment on l'appelle
tantôt certaines personnes vont dire on
est plus dans dans une demande de
réforme on n'est plus dans une révolte
on est dans une révolution c'est vrai
que certains personne peuvent parler de
de guerre civile moi je parlerai en
termes de rupture moi je pense qu'il y a
une rupture
visible physique sans équivoque d'une
rupture réelle entre la société et
l'État aujourd'hui le message est clair
on veut plus de la République islamique
d'Iran on veut plus c'est si vous voulez
c'est la c'est la confrontation de deux
mondes vous avez d'un côté un monde qui
prône et qui veut en fait gouverner
comme une société islamique et vous avez
une autre société qui a des aspirations
démocratiques et qui a une qui en tout
cas défend l'humanisme et des fois en
tout cas des valeurs ou des libertés les
plus les plus fondamentales c'est le
droit de circuler le droit de presse le
droit à la liberté de presse la liberté
d'expression la liberté d'opinion la
liberté d'exister je pense tout
simplement en tant qu'individu à le
premier sens du mot liberté c'est une
possibilité de choix c'est exactement ce
que la population iranienne n'a pas les
jeunes n'ont pas les femmes n'ont pas
les hommes non plus et c'est intéressant
de parler aussi des hommes dans cette
société parce que je pense aussi que ça
a un des premiers pays au Moyen-Orient
dans un état islamique où on a vu que
les hommes étaient aux côtés des femmes
et quand les femmes sortent aujourd'hui
dans la rue son voile aujourd'hui
maintenant les femmes c'est devenu une
résistance on va ne plus porter le voile
et c'est extraordinaire il y a des
messages qui sortirent sur les réseaux
sociaux il y a une jeune femme qui dit
mais moi de mon travail jusqu'à ma
voiture j'ai pas porté le voile c'est
une ça c'est une révolution dans le sens
où c'est des peut-être des petits pas
mais c'est un grand page je pense parce
que en fait
allez j'ai envie de dire s'il y a bien
une révolution dans ce pays pour moi
c'est une révolution sexuelle et c'est
une révolution culturelle et ça ça en
vous toutes les autres évolutions ils
peuvent rester là ils peuvent déployer
la force ils peuvent utiliser la
répression qui est finalement vous savez
la violence a toujours été la réponse
des faibles
et là vous voyez une société qui n'a
plus peur
qui qui va au nom de la liberté le sang
va couler le sang coule déjà on parle de
bain de sang un terrain vous savez il y
a cet artiste qui a coloré les fontaines
de Téhéran avec de la couleur rouge
c'est un artiste anonyme mais ça a
l'image du sang qui est coulait dans les
rues de téran et même ailleurs en Iran
malheureusement et je pense que ça c'est
la vraie révolution c'est une conscience
et c'est une révolution sexuelle c'est
quoi la différence dans la Révolution
provincement puis
les tentatives qui eux mettons dans les
20 dernières années de changer les
choses est-ce que en ce moment vraiment
on sent que le mouvement plus d'ampleur
puis qu'il y a plus de potentiels à
faire bouger les choses moi je pense que
c'est une question de génération on est
dans une génération qui ne veut plus
faire dicter et ne veut plus
qu'on lui impose des choses je pense que
si on avait peut-être des générations
précédentes plus conventionnelles qui
étaient plus docile je sans vouloir
insulter qui que ce soit on a comme ça
parfois parfois peut-être des personnes
ou des générations qui ont qui sont plus
dociles que d'autres vous avez d'autres
générations qui sont plutôt révoltées je
pense qu'on est face aujourd'hui en Iran
c'est une population jeune c'est une
population éduquée c'est une population
qui est très conscient de sa condition
sociale qui est très très mature
politiquement c'est qu'on voit des
collégiens et qu'on voit des lycéens
manifestés à l'âge de 15 16 peut-être
même 12 13 ans moi je pense que ça dit
long sur une société
un enfant de 12 ans qui crie liberté
liberté femme vie liberté pour moi ça en
dit long sur une société et ça ça montre
l'échec de l'islam politique ça montre
l'échec de toutes si vous voulez de
cette propagande et toute cette
manipulation si vous voulez idéologique
parce que c'est ça qu'ils ont tenté de
faire depuis 43 ans c'est vraiment de
faire un lavage de cerveau ça marchait
pour certaines personnes ça a pas
fonctionné pour d'autres
ceci étant dit qu'on voit comme ça des
jeunes gens crier des revendications qui
sont qui sont liées aux droits les plus
les plus les plus fondamentaux on
pourrait dire mais c'est une jeunesse en
fait finalement qui qui a une autre
maturité je pense et qui a une autre
esprit que peut-être la génération
précédente je veux rien enlever à la
génération précédente parce que c'est
quand même les parents il faut les
respecter et puis les grands-parents
aussi et les plus aînés évidemment il y
a toujours le respect de l'aîné ceci
étant dit la grande différence qu'au
moins je vois c'est que c'est une
génération de point à 0 c'est une
génération connectée c'est une
génération qui sait ce qui se passe à
l'extérieur
et qui a envie de vivre sa jeunesse
comme comme à Montréal comme à New York
comme un Berlin comme à Paris j'ai envie
de tenir la main de ma petite amie j'ai
envie d'embrasser mon copain je veux
vivre ma sexualité comme je l'entends
voilà
et vous voyez c'est ça la grande
différence moi je pense et c'est pour ça
que je parle
[Musique]
et bien elle montre aussi ses limites
parce que le mur de porc est tombé à
partir du moment où on est prêt à aller
dans des rues en Iran pour manifester
c'est que oui peut-être qu'on a peur
mais finalement on y va quand même on y
va parce qu'on croit un changement et
parce qu'on ne veut plus on ne veut plus
de on ne veut plus en fait vivre sous un
état dans une société islamique il y a
pour
me mettre dans le thème j'ai réécouté le
film Persepolis de Marjane je me suis
[Musique]
sur sa jeunesse qui montre la révolution
de 119 puis j'écoutais tantôt une
entrevue qui a donné sur la situation en
ce moment puis il y a des exactement ça
au moment de la Révolution 79 c'était
40% des Iraniens qui savaient les
réécrire aujourd'hui c'est 80% des
jeunes aujourd'hui ont accès Internet
sont ouverts sur le monde et s'informent
savent que ce qui se passe
on peut pas on peut plus difficilement
justement comme tu dis les contrôler
puis elle dit aussi puis quand je parle
aux jeunes hommes maintenant
que la femme est égale à l'homme
pour eux c'est un acquis c'est un
certitude le type c'est aucun doute
là-dessus de ces
tentatives de répression je voudrais
jamais avec une nouvelle population qui
est aussi éduquée qui était aussi
avancée absolument parce que l'éducation
amène de nouvelles inspirations
puis oui elle c'est vraiment le témoin
de ce qu'elle a vécu parce qu'elle a
aussi quitté comme beaucoup vous savez
pour beaucoup de jeunes pour venir à son
calme et c'est le cas de beaucoup
d'artistes en exil beaucoup de
d'Iraniens qui sont aujourd'hui à
l'étranger
beaucoup sont partis à cause de ce
régime beaucoup sont partis parce que
justement il voulait il voyait aucune
perspective d'avenir dans la République
islamique d'Iran et que aussi à un
moment donné surtout je pense ici aux
artistes aux réalisateurs aux acteurs
aux actrices
à beaucoup d'artistes de différentes de
différentes pratiques artistiques c'est
des gens à un moment qui si on reste en
Iran avec la censure avec l'autocensure
avec toutes les restrictions qui qui
imposaient à la liberté de création
liberté d'expression liberté de penser
il ne reste plus le choix soit on reste
on est silencieux soit on va dans la rue
au péril de notre vie soit on part il y
a pas il y a pas 36000 choix et c'est
pour ça que vous retrouvez aussi une
grande partie de la communauté iranienne
on peut parler juste de Montréal
regardez Toronto Vancouver le Canada est
devenu un des je dirais un des pays
majeurs de l'immigration iranienne après
évidemment les États-Unis et puis dans
une moindre mesure l'Europe peu importe
finalement
ou pour beaucoup des jeunes il faut
partir en tout cas pour certains qui ont
les moyens parce que partir non plus
c'est pas toujours facile et il faut il
faut certains moyens économiques pour
pouvoir sortir du pays mais pour ceux et
celles qui parviennent ne serait-ce que
obtenir un permis d'études et ensuite
demander un permis de séjour ils vont
jamais hésiter à quitter l'Iran et donc
l'Iran ces vidéos aussi on parle souvent
de ce phénomène de la fuite des cerveaux
ce pays s'est vidé de ses cerveaux vous
savez ici à Montréal on prend juste
l'exemple de Montréal regardez juste à
ma guilde Concordia HEC vous avez un
nombre important d'étudiants iraniens et
on les retrouve où en ingénierie en
médecine en informatique dans une
moindre mesure en sciences sociales
comme moi par exemple moi j'ai fait un
petit canard j'ai fait sciences
possessio c'est pas du tout valorisé
dans dans la culture irakienne c'est
même pas sérieux comme études enfin bref
il faut aller vraiment vers des vers des
vers les sciences pures parce que voilà
il tout aussi cette culture qui valorise
et qui a toujours valorisé les études
mais davantage évidemment les sciences
pures au détriment parfois
malheureusement de des sciences humaines
quoi que maintenant la tendance commence
à changer parce que même pour cette
génération par exemple il y a une
valorisation des domaines artistiques on
voit justement qu'il y a une
professionnalisation qui se fait à
traverser demain là et on peut souvent
voir que par exemple un artiste va avoir
un diplôme en ingénierie mais en fait sa
vie et sa passion c'est la peinture ou
la musique donc oui vous avez
différentes cas de figure mais c'est
vrai que beaucoup partent comme comme
argent de sa trappy et part pour des
questions souvent
politique et à cause à cause du
gouvernement et du régime en place en
Iran un artiste c'est plus plus
dangereux pour une dictature qu'un
ingénieur a par exemple absolument ce
qui est dangereux pour pour cet état
pour cette République islamique d'Iran
c'est la pensée libre et c'est là aussi
qui a une confrontation c'est à dire que
c'est la pensée unique qui s'oppose à
une pensée libre et plurielle
donc là ça fait ça fait
environ 5 semaines je pense qu'on est
dans les revendications puis dans les
est-ce que le régime en place montre des
signes de
faiblesse ou de ralentissement ou pas
vraiment
ce que c'est certain que c'est pas un
état qui veut montrer des films pardon
de faiblesse
moi je pense qu'on montre c'est très
pression aussi forte pour moi c'est un
signe de faiblesse d'esprit surtout
parce que s'ils étaient matures ou si
justement ils voyaient une autre vision
du monde que la vision très
comment dirais-je très limité ce qu'ils
ont en ce moment c'est certain qu'ils
auraient pu aller vers d'autres options
ils auraient pu ouvrir le dialogue ils
auraient pu tenter de créer une
discussion ils auraient pu tenter même à
travers les autres mouvements de tenir
au moins en considération peut-être pas
toute la revendications mais de répondre
à certaines revendications qui étaient
d'ailleurs assez légitime donc nous la
réponse de l'État iranien c'est toujours
de dire
il y a aucune place il y a on ne tolère
aucune critique vis-à-vis de l'État
vis-à-vis de la figure religieuse figure
religieuse et politique ne font donc de
facto si on laisse aucune place à la
critique vis-à-vis du religieux
évidemment aucune place vis-à-vis d'une
critique vis-à-vis de la figure
politique donc oui on laisse aucune
place à la critique on laisse aucune
place à la remise en question du système
et donc c'est la répression c'est le
déploiement d'une force de frappe qui
est souvent qui est souvent la réponse
alors après dans le parlement iranien la
ridjani qui a un des députés a dit
peut-être qu'on va revenir sur cette
question du voile peut-être qu'on
pourrait rediscuter du code
vestimentaire etc alors pour certains il
pourrait dire peut-être à ce que c'est
un signe de faiblesse est-ce que ce
qu'ils vont un petit peu reculer moi je
pense que ça fait partie d'une stratégie
politique ils font jamais rien sans
calcul vous savez c'est jamais une
générosité c'est jamais un cadeau qu'on
donne c'est pas une ouverture d'esprit
c'est une stratégie politique ils vont
tenter parce qu'ils essaient de te
calmer les choses avec la répression ça
marche pas on a vu maintenant ça fait
vous l'avez très bien dit maintenant on
est à plus de 20 jours donc la
répression montre ses limites c'est à
dire qu'il voit comme malgré le
déploiement de cette force de frappe les
gens continuent à venir dans la rue
alors là maintenant ils vont peut-être
essayer d'autres stratégies ils vont
essayer d'autres stratégies et ils vont
peut-être emmener des réformes ça c'est
une hypothèse possible sauf qu'on n'est
plus à l'heure des réformes c'est que
les Iraniens là quand ils sont dans la
rue ils disent pas on va réformer le
système
on veut plus du système on veut plus de
votre système et on veut plus de votre
lecture et de votre modèle de société on
est vraiment ailleurs maintenant on est
c'est trop tard maintenant des réformes
et c'est trop tard de de vouloir essayer
de faire des stratégies et des compromis
on est plus dans ce temps là
une figure qui sort du lot pour
canaliser
la révolution ou non parce que j'imagine
que
la proposition c'est de tasser le régime
en place ça prenait ça prend une
alternative est-ce qu'il y a cette
proposition là est-ce qu'il y a ou c'est
vraiment une espèce de collectif de tout
le monde qui vont régler ça une fois que
eux vont être d'or oui ça c'est une très
très bonne question le problème c'est
que une des faiblesses aussi parfois de
ce genre de mouvement et qui parfois si
on regarde les mouvements précédents qui
n'a pas abouti bon évidemment c'est
parce qu'il y avait la répression
certainement c'est la répression qui a
d'abord tué l'élan si vous voulez
[Applaudissements]
exactement mais l'autre raison c'est
parce qu'il y avait pas de leader
malheureusement il y a pas d'alternative
il y a pas de leader et il faut savoir
aussi que quand on regarde la population
iranienne vous regardez juste la
diaspora iranienne ici c'est une
diaspora qui est quand même pas mal
divisé politiquement ils ont pas les
mêmes couleurs politiques il y en a
certains qui sont pro royalistes
d'autres qui sont pro à communistes
voyez on a différentes tendances le
problème à ça il y a aucun souci d'avoir
différentes couleurs politiques c'est
correct le problème à ça c'est que il y
a pas d'entente sur un leader
et je pense que ce qu'il faut voir
aujourd'hui c'est un collectif c'est un
collectif qui a pour objectif de mettre
fin un système après je pense que comme
tu l'as très bien dit peut-être dans un
deuxième ou troisième étape il faudrait
sérieusement parler de c'est quoi
l'alternative et la chose la plus
dangereuse c'est que même si on regarde
les autres pays
du Moyen-Orient ou des pays même si
l'Iran n'est pas un pays arabe mais si
on compare avec des pays arabes
musulmans ce qu'on se rencontre c'est
que à chaque fois qu'on y a eu un
changement et un départ en fait de du
gouvernement en place ce qui est arrivé
n'a pas été en fait une meilleure option
donc ça c'est toujours le danger de dire
qui va venir après ça va être quoi
l'alternative à l'heure où je vous parle
il y a pas d'alternative il y a pas de
nom il y a pas de groupe qui s'est
manifesté ou qui en pas bénéficie d'une
forme de légitimité pour l'ensemble de
la population iranienne est-ce que de
garder le système
démocratique avec les présidents qui
étaient lu mais de
[Musique]
en tassant justement le côté
du leader du Guide du prime est-ce que
c'est quelque chose qui potentiellement
pourrait tout par de même coup est-ce
que tu peux répéter la question j'ai pas
bien on a le président qui qui était lu
versus le guide du prime est-ce qu'on
peut se débarrasser du Guide suprême en
gardant l'autre l'autre partie qui est
plus démocratique si on veut ou faudrait
tout assez du même coup il y a plein
d'hypothèses possible le gros souci
c'est que ils sont tous liés les uns par
les autres c'est tout un système en fait
c'est vraiment un clan c'est vraiment
tout un système qui se tient les uns par
les autres c'est tout simple pour moi ça
fait partie d'une seule et même classe
qui est une classe minoritaire
j'ai pas envie de des lits de dire élite
parce que pour moi c'est pas une élite
mais c'est un clan c'est un groupe de
personnes qui ont le monopole de la
force qui ont qui ont les pleins
pouvoirs
et qui font partie du même système et ça
reste en fait un groupe de privilégiés
donc peut-être qu'à l'intérieur il
pourrait avoir des divisions peut-être
qu'à un moment donné souvent on a parlé
des Gardiens de la révolution qui
pourraient finalement assez rigide
contre le guide suprême ou contre l'État
sauf que le problème c'est que
l'ensemble de ces organes est l'ensemble
des différents acteurs qui composent le
système ont des privilèges avec le
pouvoir actuel
et généralement les privilégiés veulent
jamais ils veulent pas faire changer les
statico et puis veulent pas remettre en
question leurs propres privilèges
est-ce que en ce moment
les revendications gangs du momentum
plus tard avant ou bien on s'assemble se
calmer est-ce que c'est quelque chose
que tu penses qu'il va continuer de
prendre à l'ampleur faire boule de neige
encore encore plus
[Musique]
c'est difficile à dire parce que les
informations qui qui viennent arrivent
un peu en compte donc
moi je pense que la mobilisation va
continuer la répression va continuer
aussi
ce qui s'est passé ces derniers jours
bon il y a eu vous savez il y a eu un
cyberattaque à la au journal télé donc
pendant quelques secondes on a montré la
photo justement du Guide suprême à
l'iromeni avec un viseur sur sa tête
entouré de flammes et donc il y avait
des messages de il y avait des messages
de menaces en disant ben voilà c'est la
fin pense à partir et puis il y avait
les photos des victimes qui étaient en
bas de la page donc c'est vraiment la
chaîne nationale en plein journal
Téléjournal il y a eu cette attaque ce
qu'on appelle cyberattaque ça a duré que
quelques instants mais c'était
intéressant de voir comment finalement
on est en train de s'organiser là les
Iraniens commencent à s'organiser il
bénéficie de d'une solidarité à
l'international il y a des gens de plus
en plus m'ont beaucoup de gens le
silence en disant
ma question que je voulais poser c'était
par rapport à ça c'est qu'en est-il de
l'appui international parce que
il y a aucun personne qui prend position
personne semble vouloir se mêler de ça
tout le monde semble vouloir laisser
laisser l'Iran mettre de son propre sens
qui est j'imagine essentiellement
ce qui va se passer mais l'appui est
international est où
c'est une bonne question c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'on reproche en fait à
tous les démocrates de ce monde en
disant où vous êtes en fait et ce
silence est considéré comme criminel
parce que on est en train de de tuer des
gens on est en train de faire
disparaître en fait des personnes de
manière si facile de manière si aisée et
c'est vrai que la population iranienne
et puis même la diaspora elle est
communauté les la communauté iranienne à
l'extérieur du pays ce sont aussi
révoltés et indignés par ce manque en
fait finalement de prise de position bon
il y a eu des condamnations au niveau du
discours politique en disant on condamne
ce qui se fait en Iran bon on a même
entendu de la part de Monsieur juste un
Trudeau des sanctions exactement ils ont
pris la décision évidemment de cibler
des personnes qui sont sur le territoire
canadien qui seraient ici probablement
pour faire de l'espionnage espionnage
industriel ou autre
on a vu aussi certaines personnes ont
été identifiées dans les manifestations
l'art Montréal d'ailleurs dernièrement
il y a une vidéo qui circule beaucoup
sur les réseaux sociaux où on montre en
fait un homme qui a pris des photos et
des vidéos des manifestants et puis il
est parti sauf qu'il a eu une
intercation avec d'autres jeunes
d'autres manifestants en disant
qu'est-ce que tu fais tu travailles pour
qui
critique le gouvernement publiquement
pourquoi tu participes pas au slogan
pourquoi tu dis rien et le ce monsieur a
baissait la tête puis les parties et
donc oui on a on a remarqué en tout cas
qu'il y avait des présences un peu
spécifiques dans ce genre de
manifestation parce que bon vous savez
il y a beaucoup de monde dans l'espace
public il y a beaucoup de manifestants
on sait pas forcément qui est qui mais
évidemment le gouvernement au niveau
fédéral ont pris la décision
d'identifier des personnes évidemment
ils sont interdits soit ils vont être
renvoyants en Iran soit ils sont
interdits du séjour sur le territoire
canadien alors ça c'est très bien parce
que c'est une manière de protéger la
diaspora qui est ici surtout une
diaspora qui qui est maintenant engagée
politiquement qui qui vient aussi dans
l'espace public etc
donc oui mais vous savez il est
sanctions contre l'Iran et a eu aussi
dans le passé on peut parler juste des
sanctions économiques sur le dossier
nucléaire
qu'est-ce que en quoi est-ce que ça a
contraint l'Iran il y a eu un boycott
qui existe depuis depuis la prise otage
de l'ambassade américaine en Iran il y a
eu beaucoup de sanctions vis-à-vis de
l'Iran le boycott les sanctions l'Iran a
été honnêtes impérial ils ont été mis au
bon de la scène internationale suite
justement à cette prise d'otages au
début de la Révolution
la vraie question pour moi qu'il faut se
poser c'est de comprendre pourquoi
les pressions ou les sanctions
ne fonctionnent pas
ça c'est une véritable question à poser
évidemment à des à ne représentants
politiques puis il y a à ceux et celles
qui nous gouvernent c'est de savoir
pourquoi vous ne parvenez pas
aujourd'hui avec tous les moyens que
vous avez technologiques économiques
financiers vous avez pu faire pression
sur la Russie vous pouvez pas faire
pression sur l'Iran pourquoi
c'est quoi la raison qui explique vous
réagissez pas puis concrètement vous
pouvez pas bloquer d'une manière ou
d'une autre ce que l'État iraniens est
en train de faire
des théories selon pour lesquels c'est
ça fonctionne pas pour que c'est pas
efficace pour lequel on le fait pas
est-ce qu'il y a des des
liens qui peuvent être tracés
ce qui est beaucoup ce qu'il y a
beaucoup circuler sur les réseaux
sociaux vous savez les Iraniens
adorent le débat politique ils ont très
engagé sur les questions politiques ce
qui circule dans beaucoup de critiques
c'est de dire par exemple pourquoi
Emmanuel Macron a rencontré le président
iranien à Haïti à l'assemblée générale
qui a lieu justement au mois de
septembre 2022 pourquoi ils se sont
rencontrés puis pourquoi lui a serré la
main serrer la main un dignitaire
iranien c'est hautement symbolique
de respect c'est une entente une entente
sur quoi alors vous savez l'Europe est
en train de traverser aussi un moment
difficile de son histoire surtout je
pense des pays comme la France ou
l'Allemagne par rapport évidemment à ce
qui se passe entre la Russie et
l'Ukraine évidemment parfois on dit bon
les contextes sont différents il faut
pas que vous mélangez mais ne veut pas
c'est les maillons d'une chaîne les
choses sont liées
et pourquoi les choses sont liées
pourquoi j'en reviens à l'Iran par
rapport à la Russie parce que l'Iran à
la deuxième plus grande réserve de gaz
après la Russie ça il faut pas
sous-estimer l'Iran est un très un pays
très riche un sol et un sous-sol très
riche l'Iran n'a pas seulement de
l'uranium l'Iran à du zinc il rend et du
Pétrole iront à du gaz il y a énormément
de matières premières
qui évidemment
peuvent servir les économies européennes
et donc je pense que on pourrait sans
vouloir faire encore une fois un procès
est tombé dans la théorie du complot on
pourrait se poser la question est-ce que
pour Emmanuel Macron c'est plus
important aujourd'hui de chauffer les
foyers français ou de défendre la
question des droits humains
je comprends je comprends ça
à cette quand on creuse loin ça revient
souvent à ça les gaz les ressources ça
reste un
enjeu qui est toujours à chaque fois
qu'on discute de ce genre de question là
si évidemment on n'a pas de boule de
cristal mais qu'est-ce qu'on peut penser
qui
qui va découler
des revendications comme en ce moment
est-ce que est-ce que réellement mettons
renversé le pouvoir c'est quelque chose
qui est dans l'ordre du possible ou pas
du tout
je pense que les Iraniens veulent
absolument y croire je pense que il y a
encore de l'espoir vous savez c'est
difficile pour une génération de pas
avoir d'espoir l'espoir est fondamental
dans n'importe quel société il faut
rêver il faut espérer je pense pas que
c'est un rêve mais je pense que c'est
une espérance je pense que c'est une
aspiration
si on est prêt à mettre sa vie en danger
et finalement c'est ça à combattre au
prix de sa de sa vie
c'est important comme comme
espérance et je pense que rien que pour
ça il faut valoriser cette espérance et
il faut pas le nier beaucoup de gens
vous savez vous avez différents d'écoles
de pensées certains dira mais ça sert à
rien ils vont tous ils vont ils vont
tous être tués ça va se finir dans le
même sang c'est une possibilité d'autres
personnes vont dire non non là c'est le
moment là il va il se passe vraiment
quelque chose là c'est une révolution
c'est pas une révolte il faut arrêter de
parler de révolte c'est une révolution
ça c'est notre façon de voir les choses
il y a différentes écoles de pensée mais
c'est certain qu'on n'a pas de boule de
cristal on sait pas surtout ce qu'on
sait pas c'est de quoi les tailles Rania
est capable jusqu'où il peut aller vous
savez il y a aussi
à notre malheureusement un autre
événement qui s'est passé
ces derniers jours c'est la prison des
vignes la prison des vignes il y a eu un
incendie on sait pas trop ce qui s'est
passé il y a eu des flammes il y a eu
des coups de feu qui sont sortis de
cette prison c'est quoi la prison des
vignes Evine en fait est considérée
comme une prison politique et hier je
disais à Tout le monde en parle c'est un
petit peu fait sourire tout le monde
mais je pense que c'est une réalité
la prison des vignes c'est la maison de
la culture en Iran parce que qui on
retrouve dans cette prison on trouve des
écrits des artistes des militants des
activistes des étudiants des
journalistes des avocats qui défendent à
la question des droits humains vous
savez à des avocats qui viennent
défendre d'autres prisonniers politiques
ou des étudiants mais ils se retrouvent
aussi en prison alors
c'est ça malheureusement Evelyne et donc
vous voyez ils sont en train de cibler
des groupes maintenant l'état si c'est
vrai que que la société s'organise et
continue cette mobilisation et qui
tiennent et c'est ça qui est
extraordinaire c'est que malgré
justement le déploiement de cette force
de frappe le le la population iranienne
semble quand même tenir
mais de l'autre côté l'État et commence
en fait à cibler vraiment des lieux bien
précis ils ont commencé avec les
universités ils ont touché à
l'université Sharif qui est qui était
l'univers c'était la Polytechnique à
l'époque du chat qui est d'ailleurs
justement cette universelle en
particulier est considéré comme
l'université c'est tous les élites de ce
pays qui sont à Sharif d'ailleurs
beaucoup d'étudiants Iraniens qui sont à
McGill ou a con son diplômés de l'école
de l'université Sharif parce que ça
arrive je pense en cinquième position au
moins une Orient ça arrive en 37e
position en Asie c'est quand même une
université qui est très très bien côté
sauf que cette étude cette université a
été quand même la cible
des de la police anti-émeute et du
gouvernement iranien ensuite ils se sont
attaqués aux écoles parce qu'ils ont vu
aussi que les comme je vous disais des
collégiennes des lycéens se mobilisent
ils ont enlevé leurs filles surtout à
enlever leur leur voile et elles ont
attaqué en tout cas à ces verbalement je
dirais un représentant de l'éducation
nationale et donc maintenant il
s'attaque à des écoles à des universités
et la prison des vignes qui est donc la
Maison de la Culture et en train de de
il y a des il y a des flammes qui qui en
sortent on sait pas maintenant qu'est-ce
qu'il en est qui est mort dans cette
prison qu'est-ce qu'ils sont en train de
faire parce qu'il y a des choses aussi
qui se font finalement de manière cachée
on peut pas tout filmer non plus
s'arrange quand même vous savez le fait
aussi d'avoir coupé internet c'est une
manière de couper la communication
souvent quand il y a eu aussi ces élans
de de révolte quand il y a eu ces
protestations
l'État a coupé internet à l'échelle du
pays
donc c'est une manière évidemment non
seulement d'empêcher les informations de
circuler de l'Iran vers l'extérieur mais
aussi c'est une manière évidemment
d'empêcher les communications entre les
manifestants et la population exactement
donc vous voyez c'est ça aujourd'hui ce
qu'on est en train de voir donc mais ce
qui est aussi intéressant c'est que plus
l'État va s'organiser et plus il va
déployer la force de frappe plus la
société civile va avoir des formes de
résistance des résistance créatives on a
vu toute une émergence évidemment
d'initiative aussi personnelle Shervin
qui a chanté
barillet pour à cause d'eux enfin qui
est devenu un peu lime de de ces
mouvements de contestation on a vu qui a
été qui a été chanté on a vu ses
fontaines qui ont été colorées en rouge
bon vous me direz c'est hautement
symbolique mais pour une population qui
est pas armée et pour une population qui
a un esprit créatif voilà c'est quoi la
réponse c'est la plus la meilleure arme
qu'on a mais oui on parlait été
justement de rentrer un nom on parlait
un peu de cinéma j'ai l'impression que
l'Iran malgré toute la répression une
culture super forte puis les artistes
qui rayonnent vraiment beaucoup
international on parlait de la Faraji
qui est un réalisateur primé partout
travers le monde c'est puis qui fait des
films incroyables et puis ou justement
Marjane satrapie qu'on parlait où je me
génère plein d'autres et puis
puis justement d'ailleurs ce film-là
Persépolis que j'ai écouté hier
pour comprendre plus je m'adresse au
monde qui écoute mais
parce qu'on peut parler des
faits de ce qui s'est passé mais
vraiment nous permettre de le ressentir
un peu plus de vivre un peu plus
effectivement le monde qui nous écoute à
regarder ce film là ou à regarder
n'importe quel
œuvre iranienne comprendre un peu plus
ce qui s'est passé c'est culturelle je
pense ça peut vraiment nous aider à
avoir un
implication émotive plus grande
absolument ça me fait penser à un fameux
mode André Gide qui disait l'armée de
contraintes vit de lutte et meurt de
liberté et je pense que c'est un esprit
qui qui est vraiment partagé parce qu'on
est en train de voir par ces artistes
iraniens c'est des artistes vous savez
la censure existait avant la République
islamique d'Iran l'ascenseur existe
encore aujourd'hui elle a changé de
forme elle a changé de nature elle a
changé de moyen ce qui est d'autant plus
terrible plus que la censure dans le
milieu des arts et dans la création
artistique c'est l'autocensure
aujourd'hui vous avez aussi beaucoup de
d'artistes qui se sont auteurs censurées
mais on voit à juste titre et vous
l'avez très bien dit le cinéma iranien
le fait justement d'être dans des
contextes toujours de contraintes de
censure ils ont tenté toujours de
trouver des détournements des manières
d'apporter d'amener un d'amener un
message ou en tout cas de parler
peut-être des choses qu'on veut cacher
parce que finalement le cinéma c'est
quoi le cinéma c'est aussi une belle
manière de parler de la vie de parler
des enjeux en Iran c'est assez flagrant
de partir de ces questions
existentielles de ces enjeux de société
finalement où on peut pas débattre dans
la société de manière ouverte et de
manière bienveillante
à travers le langage si vous voulez
visuel vers le langage cinématographique
on voit que ces artistes veulent
s'exprimer veulent en tout cas tenter
d'ouvrir des brèches
pour tout simplement s'exprimer pour
tout simplement avoir la possibilité
de pouvoir débattre de quelque chose
qu'il est touche individuellement ou qui
touche la collectivité dans son ensemble
on parlait de me parler justement de
qu'on commence à tourner aussi d'un
article qui était écrit justement sur
les
pour qu'on le met dans la description
puis tu nous en parler un peu oui oui
alors cette cet article a été écrit dans
la revue diplomatie ça a été dit de
publier à Paris je pourrais vous mettre
vous envoyer la version PDF puis si
jamais vous voulez le le diffuser c'est
dans le cadre en fait d'un numéro
spécial sur l'Iran donc c'est jamais les
personnes qui nous écoutent souhaitent
aller un peu plus loin aussi sur
d'autres questions liées à l'Iran le
numéro est sorti au mois d'août donc
c'est assez récent genre je vous
enverrai les références alors le
l'article en fait revient sur certains
certains films donc là je donnerai
référence justement si certaines
personnes qui nous écoutent veulent
avoir des références au niveau des
réalisateurs et réalisatrices parce
qu'il y a aussi des réalisatrices
iraniennes
[Musique]
que je vais je mentionne dans l'article
et puis ça vraiment montrer comment
aujourd'hui finalement le cinéma iranien
c'est un petit peu l'article est assez
court la conclusion c'est vraiment de
démontrer en quoi finalement le cinéma
iranien est une image des mutations
sociales donc comment justement il y a
ce dialogue qui se fait entre finalement
l'art
cinématographique et les mutations les
changements les enjeux au niveau de la
société iranienne donc j'ai vraiment
fait ce jeu en essayant de voir quels
sont les films qui abordent quel sujet
et quels sont les sujets aussi
finalement et quelle est aussi la
réalité sociale qui se cache en fait à
travers certains de ces films une
réalité finalement que l'État iranien
tente de cacher mais que le cinéma tente
de montrer et d'exposer de cette manière
là
puis
il y a une question qui t'a été posée
aussi hier à tout mon en parle puis
j'imagine c'est une question qui est
dure à répondre peut-être que la réponse
est
pas grand chose je sais pas mais tu sais
nous ici au Québec tant qu'on est
tellement de ce qui se passe et puis
qu'on voit à travers les nouvelles
travail les médias ce qui se passe en
Iran
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire il y a dessus
quelque chose que que les gens qui sont
indignés de voir ce qui se passe peuvent
je sais pas de manière ou d'une autre
contribuer
à quelque chose change oui il y a
beaucoup de choses qu'on peut faire
après c'est sûr que moi je pense que
chacun fait ce qu'il peut c'est ce que
c'est un peu ma réponse parce que parce
que je sens qu'il y a une volonté de la
part des personnes de vouloir nous
soutenir et c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment très honorable et je pense que
plus on va en parler c'est peut-être un
peu ce que tout le monde dit mais je
pense que ça fait sens parce que à un
moment il faut continuer à porter cette
voie il faut il faut continuer à en
parler puisque Internet est coupé
puisque ils ont pas la possibilité
d'aller dans les médias c'est aussi une
manière pour moi c'est une
responsabilité même si je suis pas
utologue et sociologue de formation on
se doit aujourd'hui on a une
responsabilité je pense en tant que
personne engagée tout simplement de d'en
parler de ce qui se passe de relier sur
les médias de de peut-être aussi
interroger ou poser la question à leur
représentant politique qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez faire parce que c'est sûr
que nous en tant qu'individu dans une
société
on a beaucoup moins de possibilités de
moyens qu'un gouvernement mais par
contre étant donné que ce gouvernement
est censé nous représenter et que on
leur a donné notre finalement il y a eu
finalement cette pacte au niveau de la
souveraineté je pense que faut lui
mettre un peu de pression tu sens
vouloir mettre de la pression on
pourrait leur poser la question
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez faire ou
est-ce que vous allez faire quelque
chose ou est-ce que vous est-ce que vous
pouvez faire quelque chose parce que
c'est une demande qui s'adresse
finalement de la part d'une population
pour une autre population mais
finalement on se retrouve tous sur sur
le côté humaniste on est tous on est une
planète on est un seul monde et on est
de plus en plus des des un monde sans
frontières parce que finalement on voit
ce qui se passe ailleurs pour rejaillir
ici aussi et ce qui est important c'est
de c'est de créer cette solidarité je
pense internationale et surtout demander
à ceux et celles qui nous dirigent et à
ceux et celles qui ont les moyens de
véritablement prendre des des
positions et c'est plus c'est plus loin
que des positions je pense
qu'aujourd'hui
on n'attend pas forcément un discours le
discours c'est bien le discours
symbolique
c'est c'est très honorable mais ce qui
est mieux est-ce qu'il va véritablement
changer les choses c'est des actions
concrètes il faut maintenant arrêter
d'être dans le discours il faut
concrètement qu'est-ce que ne dirigeants
peuvent faire qu'est-ce que la mairesse
de Montréal peut faire aujourd'hui moi
j'aimerais demander à Valérie plante
qu'est-ce qu'elle pourrait faire étant
donné que c'est une femme et que je sais
qu'elle a pour soucis à la question des
femmes la condition des femmes est-ce
qu'on pourrait appeler une des rues de
Montréal marcin Amini est-ce qu'on
pourrait faire en sorte que cette mort
finalement
puisse ne pas être
[Musique]
comment dirais-je en vain exactement
qu'est-ce que notre marais peut faire
symboliquement pour cette ville cette
ville il y a une grande communauté
iranienne on a beaucoup d'étudiants dont
les universités
d'origine iranienne moi j'aimerais
personnellement demander à Madame
Valérie plante à travers votre émission
qu'est-ce qu'elle pourrait faire demain
à Montréal pour les femmes iraniennes
pour la question de la liberté de toute
une population et puis qu'est-ce qu'on
pourrait faire pour rendre hommage à
marcin Amélie à Paris
madame
Hidalgo a donné une citoyenneté
d'honneur à Massa Amélie
Montréal pourrait pourrait pourrait se
positionner par rapport à ça je pense
que parfois on peut faire aussi
symboliquement mais faire un acte
concret un geste fort un geste qui peut
être la signature de notre ville notre
ville est une métropole culturelle c'est
une ville très diversifiée
à un moment donné je pense que notre
notre ville peut aussi apporter un
message et prendre une action forte et
forte et symbolique surtout et qui reste
dans le temps c'est ça aussi qui est
important que ça se parte pas que ça
s'effrite pas dans les semaines et qu'il
est moi qui viennent qu'on puisse penser
à masser un mini dans l'histoire de
notre ville pourquoi parce que c'est une
jeune femme de 22 ans parce que
sa mort
est inacceptable et parce qu'en tant que
ville on se positionne sur une lutte qui
est une lutte pour les femmes qui est
une lutte pour les droits humains
je pense que voilà je m'adresserai à
Valérie plante et puis chacun d'entre
nous on peut on peut lui poser la
question qu'est-ce qu'elle va faire pour
pour l'Iran et pour cette pour ce combat
on va essayer de faire parvenir
absolument les gens qui nous écoutent ce
qu'ils peuvent te suivre quelque part
pour poursuivre tes pensées tes ton ton
travail
je suis pas très réseaux sociaux
non je suis pas sur facebook bizarrement
je suis sur Instagram donc le meilleur
moyen de me contacter ben oui c'est par
courriel si je donne beaucoup de
conférences je donne des cours donc
c'est les personnes veulent me suivre ou
passer par la chair à Hollande je suis
attaché à l'achat à auland Durand
je suis pas sur Twitter non plus je
devrais
oui je suis un petit peu pas contre au
courant de mon époque mais je trouve que
oui les réseaux sociaux sont un outil
extraordinaire d'ailleurs on voit à quel
point ça peut servir mais c'est vrai que
oui à part Instagram LinkedIn oui moi je
ce que vous pouvez faire de toute façon
je donne des conférences et des cours un
peu un peu partout à travers à travers
le Québec je bouge beaucoup au Québec je
vais parfois dans des zones les plus
éloignées pour parler de l'Iran je suis
attachée à l'université du troisième âge
avec l'Université de Sherbrooke là j'ai
aussi donné des conférences dans le
cadre des belles heures de l'Université
de Montréal parfois avec parfois avec
l'universel ou c'est le sérum ou la
chair Raoul d'endurance il y a des
conférences qui se font sur l'Iran
parfois je suis invité parfois je suis
pas invité mais c'est pas grave il y a
d'autres personnes que vous pouvez
suivre si ces questions vous intéresse
que ce soit sur le Moyen-Orient et plus
particulièrement l'Iran après c'est vrai
que j'écris donc si jamais il y a des
gens qui sont intéressés moi je peux
leur faire parvenir soit à travers vous
mes écrits je pense que c'est ma modeste
contribution de partager mes écrits et
puis si les gens veulent me suivre sur
Instagram ils sont les bienvenus mais je
suis moins active malheureusement sur
ben je suis même pas sur Facebook et
Twitter donc voilà merci beaucoup
c'était fascinant c'était très éclairant
je peux je peux finir sur sur un petit
poème absolument c'est un poème que je
voulais lire hier à Tout le monde en
parle mais on avait très peu de temps
vous avez l'exclusivité c'est un
problème en fait c'est un poème de Paul
Eluard je veux pas vous lire
tout le poème mais j'inviterai en fait
les gens qui nous écoutent à redécouvrir
ce poème et je pense que c'est ce poème
résume bien l'esprit aujourd'hui à des
manifestants dans les rues de Téhéran et
d'ailleurs en Iran le poème s'appelle
liberté liberté j'écris ton nom et par
le pouvoir d'un mot je recommence ma vie
je suis née pour te connaître pour te
nommer liberté ça c'est le dernier
paragraphe du poème alors je veux pas
tout vous lire mais je tenais à vous
lire ce dernier paragraphe donc de Paul
Éluard liberté
merci beaucoup
aussi prochainement une rassemblement je
pense en sport au peuple iranien
c'est le troisième samedi donc ce samedi
22 octobre à 14h je pourrais vous
envoyer les informations et que vous
pouvez évidemment diffuser oui la
communauté iranienne on appelle les
Iraniens les non iraniens évidemment à
rejoindre
cette mobilisation citoyenne donc
maintenant tous les samedis de manière
assez systématique les samedis
après-midi à Montréal les gens se
mobilisent en solidarité par rapport à
ce qui se passe en Iran merci beaucoup
merci à tous les deux merci